so as Peter mentioned I'm the program
manager for the D H lab and one of the
things that I think a lot about is how
do we help students and faculty who are
interested in digital humanities methods
get started
oftentimes computation is a new
dimension to their work they might not
have experienced oftentimes they won't
have experience in programming they
might or might not know what the file
system is on their computer and they all
have different time frames in which
they're working in which they need to
complete a project depending what
they're hoping to do that poses more or
less of a problem if they're interested
in getting started with text analysis
there are a lot of really out-of-the-box
tools no programming required to get
started
oftentimes there's an entry into later
more sophisticated methods but if
they're interested in image analysis it
tends to be a little bit steeper of a
curve the approaches tend to be really
technically and mathematically
sophisticated they're oftentimes working
with thousands of algorithms are primed
for working with thousands or tens of
thousands of images as we've seen
earlier and students in faculty are
coming to me usually aren't working
quite at that scale but they are
interested in these approaches and so
how can they actually get started and if
Peter mentioned one of the reasons this
has been on our mind lately especially
in the image computation spaces we did
have a student come to us last semester
she's a master student in sculpture and
she was interested in working with this
collection of photographs of paintings
that she has around 65 photographs of an
artist that she was close with and she
wanted to know whether she could take
those photographs of these paintings and
create new images that would be in the
style of those photographs so that they
would look like that artists had created
them even though he hadn't for her this
was both an artistic project it was
something she was thinking about as part
of her program it was a research project
but it was also very personal to her
this artist that she was working with
was a very close friend and is deceased
and so it's a sort of a fixed collection
she was really very motivated and
invested in working on this project and
she had seen some of you might have seen
that Christie's recently sold an artwork
for almost was half a million dollars
that was produced with a Gans
the things that Peter was showing us
earlier you really as a lab should be
producing Gans I think for Christie's
but she was really excited by this
approach and saw that it seemed like
something that is kind of what she was
hoping to do but the problem is is Gans
do require you to have thousands and
tens of thousands of images and she had
around 65 so that wasn't gonna quite be
an approach that she could use and she
herself had no programming experience so
that was also gonna be a bit of a
barrier so we wanted to find something
that could at least get her started and
thinking along these computational lines
that could be a first pass for this
project and so neural style transfer was
the approach that we decided we would
take this is where you are combining the
content of one image with the style of
another image by way of convolutional
neural networks and we were gonna use
the code base that's produced by Justin
Johnson there's this github link and
I'll post the link again later if you're
interested in it and there were several
advantages we thought to using this
approach it works on a small scale so it
can work with just two images and though
it can work with more than two as we'll
see in a few minutes after the initial
setup it only requires a few lines of
code to run and so this meant that after
a session on the UNIX shell the student
would be able to run this code on her
own she'd be able to change some of the
parameters to tweak the output so she
wouldn't be dependent on us to run the
algorithm and make changes and our best
guesses she would actually be able to
get her hands on the code and make some
slight adjustments here or there based
on what she was seeing as the output and
this also the ability to kind of tweak
the parameters incrementally also meant
that she could get a little bit of
experience working with the code and
trying to figure out what it's actually
doing so that she could see a little bit
behind the scenes one challenge that we
had to be mindful of though was the
filter effect so as the name neural
style transfer suggests what the
algorithms trying to do is grab the
content from the content image take the
style from the style image and generate
a new output image that has the content
of one with a style of the other but
that's not exactly what our student
wanted to do she didn't just want the
style of this painting or her artists
paintings she also wanted content that
felt new and generated as well and so
even though its neural style transfer
algorithm
we were trying to think is this still an
approach that we could use to get
something that feels really generative
even on the content side as well and so
what we did is I'm gonna show you a few
experiments that I ran while we were
just trying to get our footing with what
this algorithm was capable of and then
we taught her how to do this as well and
so that she could experiment with her
own datasets but instead of showing her
datasets I'm gonna show some Kandinsky
paintings instead so for the first
experiment that we ran we just did the
defaults so we took one can let's keep
eating we took another Kandinsky
painting and we produced a third and as
you can see we have yes like we have the
style of that second one we have the
colors of that second one but we still
have all the main core content from that
first original image and this again
because we haven't changed any of the
default parameters at this point but we
could start doing is you can have more
than one style if you want it and so in
this case we're taking now four Kendon
ski paintings as our style input and by
default all of those style images are
equally weighted but you can adjust that
which is something we'll get to and so
what you're seeing is yes we're starting
to see a little bit more variation now
in terms of the final output color it's
starting to look a little different but
that content is still really the same
content and so the next step is the one
that I think starts being promising for
what the student was hoping to do which
is that you can also adjust the weights
so you can have the trade-off between
the relative weights of how much you
retain of that content image and how
much you are taking from the style
images changing the weights will result
in higher loss for each of those epochs
we were just hearing about epochs but as
a result of that you start to see
greater change with each iteration and
so you start to get something that feels
a little more transformative and so
after that point after you're mixing up
the styles and the weights really it's
just a matter of keep tweaking it try
different weight settings and see which
one starts to feel more in line with
what you're hoping to see I rather like
actually the third one I think that
looks like a nice Kandinsky painting
even though it's not exactly but what
else you could do is you can also take
from an earlier output in that epoch if
you were interested so this is I'm gonna
cycle through each 100 epochs it gives
you an output image and so again
depending what the goal is for the
project you could
take from in one of those earlier stages
and have that be an image that you want
to work with or the last thing that I'll
show is you could take the output and
use that as your new content image so
now we have an output which is already
kind of a mixed up one has a lot of
things going on with it and then we're
adding three more style images to that
and then the result feels again that
much more transformative now because
we've suddenly don't have a content
image that already had a firm content
attached to it and so I'm gonna take
that last one now and put it actually in
the context of a bunch of Kandinsky
paintings and you can see that it really
does start to have the feel of Kandinsky
without having the exact content copied
from any single one of those and so this
was something that was really exciting
to the student that we were working with
we were able to get her set up on the
computer and the cube actually is where
she did a lot of this work so she had a
key to the cube she was able to come in
anytime sterling was open run these
algorithms on her own with her own data
set she could try switching out
paintings because some images work
better as content images than others
some were Federer style images than
others and she also is starting to think
about how she might expand her corpus
even more to include things like some of
the photographs that the artist took
that inspired the paintings he then went
on to do and so mixing some of those
actual source photographs with the
actual photographs themselves to produce
something new but other ways that you
could tweak the parameters and that I
haven't shown or you could do things
like rotating the style image would have
an effect on this you could choose how
much of the color you're taking from the
content image or not you could resize
the style images so the code is actually
really flexible and has a lot of
different parameters that you might play
around with and so for anyone who's
interested in getting something up and
running or for more of the technical
back-end of it and is really interested
in the fact that we ran this with CUDA
and torch and on a GPU instead of a CPU
I recommend checking out the code on
github it's all open and then this is
the paper that inspired the code so for
anyone who's interested in exploring
with that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]